foreign
[Music]
and welcome back to Rotten Tomatoes is
wrong I am back yet again with Mr Mark
Ellis and I am back with you and happy
New Year yes we are back and it is in
the new year and we are still in the
same clothes that we were in last year
we liked them 2022. here for clothes or
maybe we're just from the past
projecting through through our lake
house mailbox oh boy
what a movie to reference when we're
talking about our favorite movies of now
last year 2022. yes definitely talking
about our favorite movies from last year
if by the way you have not I want to
make sure that folks realize it's not
just us that are talking about this you
can also go check out the folks at
Rotten Tomatoes the best movies of 2022
ranked
um go ahead and check that out as well
as the awards leaderboard which is what
I maintain weekly this is where you can
keep up to date for all the various
films what they're winning at the
Critics Choice Golden Globes and all the
various critics killed be in charge of
you know your Oscar pool and maybe know
who's supposed to win not going to say
that means you're going to be better at
picking who will win but you'll know
what they were supposed to win for well
this is true because my mom now knows
that she's playing against you when when
my mom and I do our Oscar pool and she's
got like her friends back in Virginia
that they all do the pool but they they
include Mark's ballot they all know that
that it's really you oh no I'm just I
pepper like 10 Scott Mance 90 Jacqueline
Coley and I take all of that information
I filter it into what I put on my oscar
about because I'm look I love my mom her
friends are cool I'm out for blood okay
I want to win oh my God that's so funny
I'm a competitor first and foremost
family member second I do appreciate
that this is one of the reasons why I
don't do Oscar pools anymore because I
found out when you do it as your job
people get really mad when you win and
that is the worst kind of win to have oh
it's like you work at McDonald's so you
can't play McDonald's Monopoly it's kind
of like that okay I work at a radio
station 95.5 KLOS so I get some free
concert tickets but I can't call in and
play the games this is kind of the way I
this is kind of the way I've been or so
I've been told this seems like it came
from above maybe from the side came from
the side it came from the side but it
was a very forceful side it was a very
forceful side and I heard that side you
got those side pasture airbags you're
gonna be fine this is uh a part two this
is now we're out of halftime we're
starting the third quarter but we can
give the folks who are listening a
little bit of a rundown of what we did
for our previous episode yes to give you
a recap I voted for bones and all
devotion inspection good luck to you Leo
Grande black panther wakanda forever and
Mark voted for pray Elvis hustle
unbearable weight of massive talent and
Barbarian we had a nice little like one
word thing going on yeah very nice and
clean titles yeah and this is something
that you and I need to talk about all
fair because I'm still not married to
what I'm gonna call my my new special
which uh which we taped at the end of uh
last year because I had a longer word
title for it but something came up and I
like the way it's playing so I might go
shorter I think shorter titles are the
way to go with the exception of the
unbearable weight of massive talent but
everybody's just calling that massive
Talent everyone's just got massive
talent and honestly um the unbearable
weight as well like if you can get it
like it's a compound I don't think
you're gonna be that far off from it but
yeah and I'll say this too about my list
today yeah my other five
wordy wordy wordy I have a few why don't
you start with your very first one I
don't have very many wordy ones I have
uh we'll see okay and again we're not
ranking this in order because uh because
numbers and uh math and verbal this is
not the SATs all right I don't want us
holding it to us later we can I don't
even think kids take scts anymore yeah
this is just our unofficial 10 best
films of 2022 and Mark May give you his
top film and I will continue to dodge
the question I will give you my favorite
movie of the year so I'll close with
that but for right now it is one that
just it stole my heart I had no idea
this was a movie I had no idea was
coming out never heard of it before I
heard some people bubbling about it I
heard oh yeah it's this little Underdog
Story it's the ultimate Underdog because
Jacqueline it's a freaking shell it's a
shell it does have shoes on hence the
name of the movie Marcel the show with
shoes on and it just blew me away you
talk about the Grinch's heart going
three sizes yeah ten size bigger heart
today first of all what put this one on
your watch queue because I love this
movie
but I'm I'm I'm like yeah I would not
have put this on your watch queue yeah
so for for folks listening to the show
maybe for the very first time they want
to know some good movies to watch from
last year Jaclyn's radar is like a
current U.S military grade sort of radar
my radar is basically like we're doing
the SOS we're in submarines I don't
really have a wide film radar not put
that shade on there I'm saying that this
is a very underground just like what you
were saying this had a very cult-like
following yeah and so the idea that you
even said in your thing you're like I
didn't know about this and that you
discovered it that's why I'm like oh
well this found you which is interesting
considering how it was very underground
in Indy it's such a funny title and then
I saw people tweeting about Marcel and I
saw people posting the poster and I was
like oh that's kind of cute and then
when they use words like you know warm
and cuddly and Underdog I'm like I'm
listening okay so it's it's this show
and it lives with its grandma doesn't
know where the rest of the family went
yeah and then we get 60 Minutes involved
and and this show but Marcel becomes
this viral sensation and so it's sort of
a mix of the modern world that we live
in but also just like the cute times of
Pat when we could just have a show with
shoes on yeah and that could be the
story you know ironically what it
reminded me of is the John Favre movie
Chef because in the way that that's just
such a self-contained we're just gonna
cook and we're gonna the cooking is
gonna make our lives better but then you
also have that social media angle where
he gets in hot water with the food
critic over Twitter this sort of
reminded me of that because it's just
like this we're just looking for our
family but then we have fun with YouTube
and with with influencers trying to just
make a quick buck and 60 Minutes Leslie
stalls in the movie there's a lot of
moving parts to Marcel the show with
shoes on I really love that you were
talking about Chef because first of all
with Marcel the Shell with Shoes On the
other thing that I think is interesting
about that one is for as beautiful it is
it's another Testament of perseverance
because the two people most intimate
involved in making it were a couple when
they first started making it and then
were ex-husband and ex-wife by the time
that the movie came out because
animation and stop-motion animation
takes that long oh so they basically had
a 10-year baby that they were making
together even though they had been long
since divorced but when you watch the
movie yeah it's maybe that sort of
factors in the story I think it does
factor into it so that's the part about
it that I love and Chef I love that that
was also born out of a crazy situation
because John Favreau made that because
of his anger trying to get
pre-production done for Iron Man 3. yeah
and so he went to go do Chef as his way
of being like f you guys and that's what
got him back in their good graces to
come and do like Mandalorian yeah and he
had Downy make a quick Cameo that where
he's pretty much playing Tony Stark like
it was it's a fun movie but it's not as
high the Tomato Meter is Marcel very few
movies are what is it R Marcel the sweet
little shell with shoes on and I cannot
believe how haven't tripped over that
title yet 99 certified fresh in the
Tomato Meter 91 audience score so I say
to you Jaclyn Coley beat that only thing
I can beat that with is the fact that it
got a Golden Globe nomination too oh
good oh I believe yeah I got nominee for
a Golden Globe on Tuesday so I'm happy
for it I'm very happy for this film I'm
pumped next up I have my very first film
looks in
I love that you started this so cute and
adorable uh-oh with
um an adorable little shell that talks
like this um played by Judy slate
but I'm taking us to a different place
all right
um and that is a place of sadness
and puke
and shipwrecks
and rich people behaving very very oh of
course talking about triangle of sadness
yeah this is Reuben oslin's uh Palm Dior
winning satiris comedy this is the guy
that did Force Major
um he also did the square basically the
absurdity of the world that we live in
this man can never not find a target of
that and he has assembled a cast of
relatively less known people like Harris
Dickerson folks May recognize him from
the last Kingsman movie uh also it has
Woody Harrelson obviously recognizable
but for the most part it is relatively
unknown folks also Dolly DeLeon got a
Golden Globe nomination out of this and
it was Golden Globe nominated for best
Tony it is a divisive film this is not
one of those films where like if you
watch it and you're like oh my God
Jaclyn I hated this movie I'm telling
you you should go in with caution this
is a movie that takes it there and if
you don't like that you probably won't
like this movie but I love it 70 fresh
73 audience score love love love this
movie but sometimes those movies did
have that sort of subject matter you do
tend to get a little lower with the with
the Tomato Meter and particularly the
audience score just be if it's a downer
movie Sometimes audience is just like
well that made me feel bad yeah and and
sometimes that works with critics too
this one doesn't make you feel bad this
one definitely just makes you feel like
shame and like man we are all
hypocritical and like just how
like the absurdity of our existence you
know it's like reading an onion article
that hits too close to home I have a
wonderful little story about this movie
for you what very little but involves
one of your favorite people of all time
who I don't think you've ever met in
person oh who I was doing stand-up a
couple nights ago and my buddy Kevin
Christie oh yeah yes who you love I do I
love his story we'll get him on the show
you should get next year he told me that
he had just finished his set I think he
brought me up or I brought him up on
stage and then we were talking
afterwards and we were about to leave
and he said yeah I'm gonna go finish the
other half of this movie I'm watching
with Woody Harrelson called triangle of
sadness I have not gotten the update
because he was really into it but I
don't know I haven't got the update as
to the the second half of his viewing so
so I'll I'll see
I'll see what he had to say it's
definitely a movie that traffic's and
like privilege and influence and like
yeah and just like again the games we
play to exist in this world where like
patriarchy and money and all of these
things sort of like determine how we
exist in it okay I'm in you got me it's
crazy and Woody Harrelson's pretty
hilarious in it I love me some Woody
yeah all the way back to White Ben can't
jump so and cheers really the Bart's
under on Cheers I will give you that one
cheers man honestly I feel mixed bag
about the Frasier Revival like I wanted
to be back but I feel Kelsey Grammer is
going to pull a Roseanne and so I'm like
ugh I didn't know there was a Frasier
Revival that's Frasier Revival coming
yeah I love Frazier I love that show I
love that show too but I'm just like
okay it was kind of where it it was what
it was let it be anyway go on to your
next one cheers though all time Banger
still always up yeah still does slaps as
the kids say another thing that slaps
or splashes rather would be Avatar the
way of water
on my list I've seen it twice and we
have the Tomato Meter score currently
and this is at the time of this
recording it's it just screened it had
its Premiere we've had critics weighing
in for the last week or so 85 is where
it's currently at on the Tomato Meter we
don't have an auditing score yet but I
think that's gonna be pretty high up
there and I have a feeling this movie's
gonna make a lot of money because it's
an avatar it's James Cameron it's we're
returning to Pandora after 13 years what
an accomplishment just a visual Feast I
felt like I was scuba diving for three
hours the three hour run time flew by
for me both times but it's also the
story that I'd really feel like elevates
the material from the first Setup movie
that we got I care about these
characters I care about the family more
and I have even started talking about my
true love in this movie the whales I am
full Star Trek for the Voyage Home save
the whale save the whale you know he did
get some Voyage Home on that one it was
so funny somebody said the other day
that the first one is the Ewoks when
they I saved Luke in return to the Jedi
and I'm like dang it like when she calls
AWA and ever since then I can't unsee it
I dare anyone to make this one to make
that symbol of a joke because even if
you want to make it reductive I'm like I
don't care that movie is incredible it
almost made it onto my list and the only
reason why I did it unfortunately for
that movie is I should have seen that
movie before anyone else did wait what
do you mean you should have seen it
before anyone else did like I should
have seen it like so I didn't see it on
the sixth oh so you're just upset at
yourself yeah for not getting to this I
actually saw it on December 6th that was
my first foray yeah I had like it's
award season for people that don't
realize that and so this movie like I
had travel I was literally flying to New
York okay dude press and it was just
like the travel and everything it just
did not work with also like the fact
that I had this huge work thing to do so
I was literally gonna see it at 10 A.M I
actually went to the screening and was
like ready to go but like I couldn't
stay I had to leave and it was so crappy
so I went and saw it on the 12th at that
that and I wouldn't have gone to the to
the premiere if I would have done that
and I would have seen it on that day and
walked out of it with the feeling
without knowing what anybody else felt
it would have been more special well
look we both got to see it last night
too as of this recording I'll just say
we both looked Jacqueline and I smoking
hot and we watched Avatar and again I
mean this movie the whales for me did it
but also say Stephen Lang's Marine what
an incredible villain one of the best
villain turns of the year we knew he was
a bad guy in the first one but there's a
little more three-dimensional as that
story progresses that sort of took me by
surprise but also impressed me also
really impresses me too do is just the
idea of how he comes back is kind of an
infinite loop I want to be very clear to
people that like the way they they bring
this character back makes it to where a
lot of the things that you would assume
to be true in this world are not so I
just I'm like oh man there's gonna be
lots of things I I think fans are going
to respond positively to the way that
storyline unfolds apparently some people
still can't handle Palpatine coming back
that's the force you want me to explain
the [ __ ] I I can't I'm not a Jedi or a
sit they don't even understand how the
force Works fully so back off Palpatine
and his zombie-like creation but I will
say that this is way more more
believable than that and either way I
just like the best part about way of
water is everyone's asking the question
is do we need more of these stories and
wave water absolutely says yes we do
like where they left it also makes it to
where you're like oh not only is this
great but bring us more like the Saved
by the Bell the College Years theme song
implies the there's so much more to
explore I love this very well all right
I'm going to move on to my next one
which I think we may have overlap and if
we do shout it out so
um this one look I was in with very
little
other than the director's name and the
title once I knew that I was like yep
and so I think I might know where you're
going you know what I mean so that was
enough for me and for anyone
who naysays this film I just want to
remind you that you now have the same
cinematic opinion as Logan Paul okay all
right
that's it I'm not saying that you have
to love it but if you are literally like
this does not make sense and you're like
really like in your feelings about it
just remember whose Camp you're in you
may like that
probably should
and the movie is nope yeah I mean I
thought everyone would get that nope I
mean I picked up on it right away but
then I think most of our audience
climbed on to what you were spitting
because nope is the movie that I think
you come in with such high expectations
given what you said to the director
Jordan peel get out phenomenal movie I
thought us was great as well and I liked
that I sort of like that bent on that
subject matter but then nope it's like
oh okay this is gonna be this is gonna
be the best that Jordan peels ever done
because we get some it looks like we
have some visitors and then you just
think nope like like not of planet Earth
and it's like oh okay the cast look
great Daniel kaluya back Kiki Palmer
three Oscar nominees three Oscar
nominees one Oscar winner and Steven
young he's an Oscar nominee too he's
great is he oh yeah that's right there
you go so it's just such a fascinating
tale and the way that he told it was
impressive and we also had this weird
subplot with Gordy's home keep cutting
back to that and it just it all wound up
so it's you know I guess the metaphor
for Hollywood but I also just enjoyed
the way that it shaped up I like there's
a cinematographer yeah in a customer
cinematographer who gets the ultimate
shot yeah is where we'll leave that and
I thought that storyline was tremendous
and again Keke Palmer one of the best
performances of the year everybody's
great in the movie she steals that
entire picture not to again just keep uh
keep spouting out of words but she did
win New York Film critics and that is
not the typical role that that would go
to like there's a ton of female
actresses like I don't know Kate
Blanchett
um
again that's lead performances of course
as opposed to supporting but the idea
being the same is like that's the type
of caliber performance that is typically
honored by that group and so for KiKi to
be honored for it is like really really
exceptional also the other thing I will
say about nope is it's like 82 certified
fresh 69 fresh for the haters sorry uh
but it's still fresh uh and the other
thing about it is it continuous history
of just being crazy successful three
films over 100 million dollars like
Jordan peel is IP now he can make that
kind of sort of claim to say when his
movies are in the theater people show up
for it yeah he's got that pedigree where
where it's a theatrical experience
because you I mean you look at Spielberg
this year and I don't know if the
filaments is going to be on your list or
not but the it seems like not even the
name Spielberg can get just butts and
seats anymore yeah just be unless it is
something like if he's doing a Ready
Player One people are going to want to
show up to see Blockbuster Steven
Spielberg but Christopher no one's on
that list yeah uh Jordan peels on that
list and it's and it's exciting to watch
I have a question for you about this
movie because this we get this
conversation every so often I just
wonder where you stand on it is a lot of
folks were saying nope and they were
defending it by saying that you need to
see it two or three times no I only saw
it once I've seen bits and pieces since
then because I'm just kind of fascinated
in how Jordan peel put the movie
together but what is the argument that
you need to see it twice does that hold
any validity because I do think there is
there's some movies that really do
reward you for re-watching them yes but
I think it's not in the way that people
think so many people are used to the
Ryan Johnson M Night Shyamalan if you
watch this you'll see breadcrumbs to the
twist
type re-watching this gives you a reward
what I think note people should be
saying what I hope they're saying if
they say re-watch it again is what you
see is not nods to what the twist is but
you see little details to what he's
trying to say besides the action because
it's almost like with his movies there's
something underneath everything like the
idea that this being this All-Seeing Eye
like maybe an audience is chewing up all
of these performers and spitting them
out just because they're seeking
entertainment and a way to find where
they're supposed to be that's like what
the Steven like there's a lot more going
on and I think that's what people are
suggesting but unfortunately when you
say it like that it's like well
shouldn't this play on its own one time
and it does it does though that yeah
that would that would have been my
defending it's like I saw the movie Once
start to finish and had a I picked up
some of the metaphors I picked up some
of what the the the the breadcrumbs yeah
unfortunately they're just doing a bad
job of the messenger because they're
saying you should watch it a second time
which makes it either seem like oh well
you just didn't get it when in actuality
it's like no this is a this is a soup
that has like a second flavor in a
minute you know what I mean like where
you like taste it originally and then
you have like that like oh that's like a
spice to it you didn't feel it at first
apparently that's what you do with uh
with marinara too and I'm learning this
well because you know you hear that like
sometimes food that you make is better
two days later yeah like people love
Thanksgiving leftovers I'm not one of
those people I have I have the turkey
day and then I'm back to my usual diet
of uh my weekly chicken and Pizza but
with nope I I feel like that is like a
stew or it's like a marinara for our
Italian friends gravy where it's like oh
you made it and it's delicious the first
night the second night or chili yeah
Chili's like that too so which I guess
is kind of a soup yeah I guess that is a
soup that is a soup
let us know your comments RT is wrong at
Rotten tomatoes.com
I was literally contemplating that and I
was like you know it's the consistency
and that's the problem it's like the
minute you say it I have to start
contemplating where it goes what's your
next choice of my next choice in this
stew of movies of 2022 is
everything everywhere all at once people
have heard me on this show and other
platforms not rail against but I'm just
tired and I'm just kind of bored and the
Multiverse in the MCU even when the
spider people were coming through just
never really got my goat I just never
really it never really tit awaited me
and then I saw everything everywhere all
at once and I'm like okay we can use a
Multiverse device to tell incredible
stories this one blew me the F away I
was I was so entranced and I had heard
some good things about it I saw it
pretty early in the game but I was not
prepared for the Breakneck speed that
this thing just it Gras as you the movie
starts and boom we are locked in yeah
and you got to be prepared for that and
it I I had to catch my breath after the
movie it's really funny because you're
right because it comes from this very
like stagnant like we're going like
fighting on our taxes how boring is that
like this is the most mentality of life
and then we end up in the most
Fantastical places that you can imagine
possible the thing I would say about
everything everywhere all at once which
is kind of incredible and sort of I
would say groundbreaking in it is the
fact that despite it being that it's not
just a multi it's not a movie that is in
a Multiverse it is a movie about the
Multiverse and I think that is where
some of these movies that are just
within a multi Multiverse don't make uh
the right distinction which is that what
is the implications of this new found
information this idea that like there
are multiple lanes and the idea that if
some people when they find out that
information they're not going to use it
in the most positive ways like I liked
how honest it was about that as opposed
to the MCU it's like sure everyone knows
there's a Multiverse but nobody would
ever do anything nefarious towards it
yeah and it's like oh it's a nice excuse
to get McGuire and Garfield backer hey
look here's John Krasinski it's Mr fancy
it just it doesn't doesn't do anything
for me other than just the it's cotton
candy to me me yeah and now maybe the
MCU can can turn course and maybe
Ant-Man and Quantum Mania blows my mind
and I'm like oh thank God we got the
Multiverse not there yet I enjoy the
spider verse animated style but
everything everywhere all at once it's
another movie kind of like nope where
it's like you don't have to watch it
twice or three times like I've done but
man does it continue to reward upon
repeat viewings Michelle yo uh kihoi
Kwan just and and if for no other reason
the fact that we got to see Short Round
from Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom
the back into prominence Stateside and
get a picture with Harrison Ford at I
think it was a convention or a screening
or an award show just to have them have
that picture again together it was
beautiful I so
this is one of those moments where I
gotta give a name drop please do but
it's a good name drop okay
so I did a conversation with Harrison
Ford when uh for
1923. it's on my Instagram oh yeah
listen though I didn't get this news day
of yeah no you've changed I what do you
mean changed I thought changed I took a
little who does that hey I interviewed
somebody cool today like where are some
friends with that person I I thought I
was okay no you're not and you know that
okay I will know in future if I do
anything with Harrison Ford to make sure
you're aware of it yeah Indiana Jones
okay the whole point being is I think
he's been people have been talking to
him about the movie because when he was
doing press for that he like was like
legitimately if you asked him about he
was like I've seen it like he was like
leaning into it because he was like yeah
you know like this is like a whole thing
oh that's so cool yeah but but the movie
again I the only thing I would say about
everything everywhere all at once is
like for for some family members maybe
you're excited to uh to do this
um it I I think that you have to
recommend it to people but let them know
like hey buckle up for this yeah because
this is not a movie you put on at home
and you can just kind of check your
phone occasionally put all the social
media devices away and or you'll be lost
yeah I mean as of you know again we're
taping this a couple weeks before it
comes out obviously the fablemans and
everything everywhere all at once seem
to be those Front Runners they do have
some front runner status the worst thing
in the world is for Steven Spielberg who
according to key like has said that like
has helped him immensely throughout the
years and it's still on his Christmas
list you know what I mean
um he is probably more than likely going
to be the reason why that man does not
get an Oscar if Paul Dano as playing
Steven Spielberg's father or more likely
Judd Hearst playing Steven Spielberg's
Uncle win best supporting actor over him
which is very likely to happen well but
you know regardless of who wins or even
who gets even getting it to the dance at
his stage get into the dance and I think
we we all need as many Positive Vibes
like that at the Oscars this year as we
can get absolutely
I just want a big hug Fest at the Oscars
I think this year the Oscars are very
invested in that all physical contact be
consensual you
we're not doing it we've been one that
we do at this table I'm just saying
we're ready to host the Oscars start the
campaign I will let you take that take
that all by yourself I'll be your
announcer
I'll be your announcer which is all I'm
good for my voice and my knowledge okay
here's what we'll do with you because I
think you'll love this role you are
going to be the mic'd up seat filler so
every time somebody has to get up to
like get an award we put you in the seat
then I can do crowd work with you at
various spots and it's like a running
bit throughout the night this is what's
so bad is like the reason why this
podcast has any amount of success is
that I forget that we film it like
that's not like that's not gonna happen
that's that's why we do this like if I
ever remember that we filmed this I
would never do it again we're gonna move
on to my next one and you're not gonna
convince me to go stand in front of
billions of people okay well don't worry
when you when you reveal your final two
movies on this list don't worry we'll
turn the cameras in the mics off shut up
if you can just aim towards the mic just
for you know play along with the game I
mean this one's gonna be really boring
and I hope you're ready for to talk
because I don't really have them come
back with because uh my selection is
actually also everything everywhere all
at once
also
this is why I'm like you're getting
cocky dude you're about to be back on
mother
flipper that's why episode one was so
listenable is because I was saying like
hustle and pray and you're you're
talking about these Indie movies but now
we're starting to yeah but did you have
nope I did not have okay no no I do have
nope so
oh yeah I have no too I just realized I
have no um you should have said that
earlier I literally forgot you know
what's funny I just have my list because
apparently I wasn't allowed to see Queen
Chloe's list before we went to air see
what emperor Ellis had either I'm I'm
zombie Emperor so I was looking at the
list and you said nope and I was just
assuming like oh okay it's on my list
but I think this may be the one that we
share yeah okay I might have dropped
them I'll show you we don't we're not
maybe we'll host the Oscars next year
maybe maybe this year's a little too
ambitious but yes nope was great
we would have we would have an envelope
Fiasco absolutely go ahead okay question
for you again what do the Oscars want
more than ratings they're saying when
did you I think you saw this movie
before I did everything everywhere all
at once no I saw this movie late and in
fact the Daniels I really hope you don't
listen to this because we had so much
fun on that Twitter space I don't want
you to know this but I had to watch it
the Tuesday before I interviewed them
because if I recall correctly did it
come out in March yeah yeah it was a
that is still award season it all is now
it feels like still award season and it
sucks but it was like right still in the
middle of like busy times if I'm recall
correctly or like right immediately
follow I'm looking at the release date
yeah I if maybe I'm wrong March 25th
March 25th yeah and I believe if we look
at that the Oscars this past year was
like March you know something yeah it's
it it's it's I mean you're right so
that's like the culmination of award
season and I was like busy okay and then
you got like what half a nap before this
Prestige movie that everybody loves
comes out March 25th like what the hell
I didn't see it I gotta go
but wait when you have a movie like that
that is so early in the year and and
there's a couple other I mean nope came
out in the summer there's another movie
on my list I'll talk about those earlier
in the year but some views are fine do
you feel like are we still in that space
where okay this movie's good but it's
March and there's no way we're gonna
remember this I mean it used to be but
now if I'm being really honest
unfortunately coming out now you may get
lost in the jumble
it might be beneficial to come out early
because with all of the listicles and
honestly with the way they kind of
divide this honestly I think these
movies should just pick it based on when
they think is the best time that these
movies can make money the problem with
that is what would end up happening is
they can't use Festival reviews as part
of the release schedule because that's
the thing they don't ever talk to you
about is the fact that like whatever
people are tweeting out out of Venice
and whatever that like people tweeting
out about don't worry darling in Venice
is why it has a 40 million dollar
opening when it comes out because that
made this a spectacle because so many
that is not the type of press that movie
would normally be able to Garner the
kind of worldwide press of people being
like did you know this movie's coming
out come watch it to see what the drama
is yeah I'm pretty sure most of that 40
million dollar opening was not based on
the tweets about the movie coming out of
the film no but this is the thing yes
Harry Styles has fans or whatever but
like legitimately also there were just
random people who were like not as
invested who just like messy drama who
are like let me go see what this is all
about there's also those people too and
they give out free salad dressing
opening weekend stop listen why don't
you move on to your next one since I
already said everything everywhere all
at once don't say no don't say nope okay
so I have so far have Marcel the Shell
uh with shoes on I have Avatar the way
of water where apparently they have four
to five things
fingers I'm not sure nope everything
ever all at once and then and I will say
my favorite movie of the year it's not
going to come as a shock to anyone at
least of which would be Jacqueline Coley
top gun Maverick my favorite movie of
the year and not the least of which
reasons is because I had to wait 30
four years for this movie and then two
bonus years for this movie to finally
see it because I thought I was finally
getting it in 2020 and that nope that
ain't happening anymore and then it got
put on the shelf for a whole long bitter
season of two years the fact that they
kept that under wraps from you there's
got to be just a slight bit of anger
because they had that greatness they had
the greatest and it was just sitting on
a shelf and when the pandemic started
you know you saw some streaming services
popping up HBO Max Paramount plus and
I'm like oh you know what's gonna happen
is that they'll make a deal with
Paramount plus and we're gonna get to
see I'll pay 40 bucks to watch top gun
Maverick in my top gun I'm glad that
didn't happen I don't say that about
many movies but I'm glad that did not
happen with top gun Maverick because
that is a theatrical experience in a
different way than Avatar but on a par
with Avatar as far as you needed to see
that movie on the biggest screen with
the loudest sound system possible
because they're actually flying the Jets
in this movie kids and and that's just
the tip of the iceberg as to why I love
this movie so much I I just want to tell
me some more obviously like legit like
well I don't need to be here for this
this is about you this movie would have
been good enough as like a Mission
Impossible film where it's Tom Cruise
what's he gonna do this time he's gonna
get in a jet and fly it around and he's
really doing it but the fact that it's
Top Gun and it has that pedigree and it
mined the story of the original 1986
film in all the right ways without going
cheesy with it without getting sappy
with it you felt the connection and so I
would give a shout out to folks like who
were mentioned the first movie like
Penny Benjamin played by Jennifer
Connelly in this movie but then you also
have goose who practically is a
character in Top Gun Maverick he's like
a force ghost that's always sort of with
mad when he flies and now he's sort of
with rooster his kid played by Miles
Teller when heath-wise and we're all
training for this Mission so funny that
uh that okay so I went to go see this
movie a number of times right one of the
people a friend of the show Steph Sabra
of the World Girls she was at the
screening and she just seen the original
Top Gun the night before she had never
seen it before and she's like yeah I
really liked it but it's kind of weird
like the whole movie was just practice
and I'm like you know what I never put
it in terms like it's just it's we're
practicing and then we get a mission at
the end we get a lot more practice here
but the mission at the end of this movie
yeah it's got so many layers it's got so
many Feats we got not one but two
Miracles and then a bunch of other stuff
going on it becomes Behind Enemy Lines
at one point and just everything
emotionally with the story lines of the
of the characters and either you know
living up to who you want to be or who
your dad was or finding love and
accepting that maybe need to let go ice
man popping in and then the jet action
God damn this is a great movie I love
this movie and I and now I'm at the best
like right now is the best time to have
top gun Maverick a thing because I've
been doing a lot of flying I was getting
ready for my special so I was doing a
lot of touring gonna go home for the
holidays and on every plane ride that
was cross country
top gun Maverick was a movie option and
it makes that flight go by in no time
man that was so good I'm just I wanted
to listen to more of it and honestly the
only thing I will add is it was a AFI
top film recently as well as best
cinematography at the Los Angeles Film
critics Association and MBR just voted
at the top film overall this is this has
got best picture I like where you're
going with this so for nominations I
think best picture we we got 10 slots we
could fill do you see something for Tom
Cruise
that depends it really does depend
because supporting actor is weak but
also one thing I realized I accidentally
asked you to go and do Top Gun because
we realized that we had two of the same
and then I counted wrong so I need to go
through too quickly that's okay but I'll
just leave you with this top gun
Maverick 96 certified fresh 99 audience
score those are two I mean and it's 1.5
billion dollars at the box office we'll
see what Avatar does
box office wise but that's the highest
box office total of the year worldwide
too oh my god well yeah giddy up Top Gun
and unfortunately or fortunately I don't
know if Avatar can make that dent
it'll be it's a crowded holiday season
do you just do you just feel meh about
Top Gun it's not that I feel mad about
it I feel very great about it it's just
not the movie that I was like I want so
every movie that I mentioned on this
list were movies when I walked out of
him I was like yes okay that is okay
like that is it and Top Gun is like that
was great but that is not me you know
what I mean like these are me movies
these are movies that I'm like no matter
what like I will put this on and when
you get through these like I would put
any of these on right now and I would be
with it and Top Gun definitely probably
Falls in that list but there's some days
that I wouldn't put that on I didn't
walk out of that theater I ran yeah up
to the managers like can I go again
exactly can I ride again exactly even
bones and all I would still watch that
again at least aspects of it I don't
like to watch that oh my God that's so
funny all right so the other one I'm
just gonna go through this quickly
that's woman King I've talked enough
about this movie I've done so much
pressure oh yeah this is Gina Prince by
the wood I just I'll just put this this
way every aspect of this movie it was
produced by a black woman it was
directed by a black woman it stars black
women it had a black editor that was a
woman and a production designer and like
everything it had Terence Blanchard a
black man who's like scored tons of
incredible black women doing the score
behind it and it was just like
everything us and it stars people like
Viola Davis and Lashana Lynch and tuso
and um yeah it's just it's dope so
anyway 94 certified fresh and 99 fresh
on that one and it was a huge success
obviously gonna be up for Oscars like
and great action and great action the
costumes like the opening sequence it is
literally on YouTube if you just are
looking at this movie and saying
whatever you want to say about it just
go on and watch that opening sequence of
like Viola Davis and those women just
coming up silently from the grass and
tell me that wasn't lethal it is so
lethal all right Mark this is the one
where
I know that honestly if I was going to
pick my favorite movie of the Year this
might be the one that I would feel the
most confident in saying you're not
putting that pressure on your child but
you I I put that on mine one this is the
one where if you had to be like which
because honestly it is just it's beyond
politics
it is beyond borders it is beyond
language the brand that I'm speaking of
what they are able to Terry and Megan
documentary on no no this is bigger than
that this is anti-colonialism this is
socialist this is capitalist this is
everything that we are as Humanity
whatever you are it will unite you gay
straight transist but it does not matter
this is
what will unite the people what could
this movie be it is a group that has
been a part of our minds and a part of
our hearts for decades and although
there have been losses
and trials and tribulations throughout
it still remains that thing that brings
so much of its Joy
and that is watching drunk skater boys
kick each other in the nuts
ladies and gentlemen I'm talking about
jackass forever
these cinematic Masterpiece yes that
still to this day I remember it was a
like I know this movie was important to
me because it might have caused an issue
with the person that lives in my house
so the person that lives in my house and
I I said hey there's a new Jackass movie
and I want to see it in the theater and
this is the thing that normally happens
when there's like content like that and
it'll be like well aren't you just like
gonna go to the premiere or like aren't
you just gonna go to like a screening
for work like why are we like buying a
ticket for this and I was like no
I will buy a ticket for this because
I've bought a ticket to every Jackass
movie since they started making jackass
movies have you because I am an elder
Millennial and that again it crosses
boundaries it's never not funny it's
never not funny to watch people get
kicked in their junk it's not just funny
it takes you it the laugh is different
it transports you to a place of ecstasy
from giggling so hard it hurts but you
can't stop it's it's the best workout
yes that I had in a theater even over
top gun Maverick where I was just
sweating on the edge of my seat
excitement cranking popcorn into my face
jackass it's dangerous to me it's a
jackass stunt to try to eat food during
that movie because it's all coming back
up absolutely and that was the other
thing we saw it at the Alamo Drafthouse
so we were definitely like tempting fate
but we did not care that's the jackass
way ladies and gentlemen yeah you got a
couple adult beverages in you oh my God
I will admit I am a very sane and
rational person but on any day I watch
one of those movies you might convince
me to like do some Fear Factor stuff you
could you could I love that stuff so
much it's just funny and they found a
way to update it comedians you're just
bad comedians jackass is a bunch of
white Suburban Bros who have a high
tolerance for pain kicking the crap out
of each other and they found a way to be
inclusive your comedy sucks and they
found a way to Usher us into a new
generation absolutely with people like
Rachel Wolfson and it sort of does have
shades of a great film like a top gun
Maverick where it's like a passing of
the torch and it's Johnny Knoxville
realizing hey maybe I can't do this to
my body as much anymore so let's get
some new folks in here there was some
real like adult male therapy going on
with those men being like I don't need
do this anymore that was like a gross
that was growth and still it's still we
get people punching each other in the
balls I just this is what we want I love
jackass from its days of just being a
show on MTV and I don't know and again
if I could go back in time you know I
would say what concert would you see
what if I go back in time and see one
movie in a theater opening weekend I
never saw any of the jackass movies in
the theater oh my God no and see that
was the other thing is I always saw them
in the theater because they are a
communal experience like that's the
other kickers I should be very clear a
jackass movie is a communal experience
because you see people that are like oh
like they scream and like turn their
face is the same thing that somebody
else is just inherently laughing
uncontrollably at the thing that some
people like literally are like turning
their face away from there's another
person that's like yeah
you would be hard for us to find a
better theater movie than that and I'll
say it in terms of this like people get
excited to go see Rocky Horror Picture
Show yes or even something like Monty
Python the Holy Grail where you know
everything that's coming but it's still
fun and it is that Community experience
and you forgive the talking a little bit
you forgive all the other stuff that you
know if I'm trying to watch uh you know
pray on the big screen if I'm trying to
watch Marcel the Shelf I'm watching nope
for example I'm like no I want to focus
I want to hear everything but with
something like jackass you want
everybody to just express yourself yeah
and those are sometimes the best movie
experiences that's why I love horror
movies it's because everybody gets
scared together but comedy a good comedy
like Bros everybody's laughing together
but you are exploding with things you
did not know you had inside you watching
a jackass movie absolutely and this the
best part rewatchability is incredible
because there's always going to be some
moment where you will have your eyes
closed from laughing and there's always
somebody who hasn't seen it yet that you
can have come over and be like I'm gonna
you're you're the guinea pig today and
then you get to just watch their
reaction as they watch it anyway I I
love this movie franchise and 85
certified fresh certified fresh streak I
might ad of Jackass and a 91 fresh
audience score it just doesn't get any
better than that you won the list Wars I
think because I'm proud of every movie I
put fourth uh as I'm sure you are but
just looking at your list comprehensive
is the word I would use for Jacqueline
Coley's list I mean it is
the reaction I have with
which I walked out of them in that like
like I skipped at a triangle of sadness
nope I was like oh I gotta watch this
again I gotta know what happens woman
King I was like this is some wish
fulfillment you know like everything had
that like with bones and all I'm like
this is so sexy even though they eating
each other you know what I mean I loved
how they were able to do that yeah I
think I'm looking at my list and like my
childhood got served a little bit and
then my adult interest as well I'm gonna
give a shout out honorable mention we
did the whale for me just because
Brandon Frazier and the rest of the cast
were so good but I also say RR was just
oh the action the dancing everything in
that movie was just a Triumph but I'm
looking at like so stuff like prey and
Top Gun that's like well you know I grew
up watching Top Gun and Predator movies
and to have them back in the way they
are Elvis always interested in a biopic
like that hustle basketball have you
ever met me for five seconds the
unbearable way to massive town it's just
a fun sort of you know metal looking at
Nick Cage Barbarian I'm a comic I travel
a lot that speaks to me Marcel the Shell
adorable it's Molly the Wonder Dog in
Shell form avid tar blew me away in a
theater nope I love Alien movies I love
Jordan peel I love a mix of comedy and
horror and figuring out what's going on
and then everything everywhere all at
once you cannot underrate how great it
is to go into a movie theater not
knowing much about something and just
being blown away so it's fun to
celebrate trailers Indiana Jones 5 looks
cool and we get to see it in six months
sometimes I love not seeing any material
related to a movie and just walking in
and just seeing what do you got I do
love that also I might add I stand by
what I say I have a reputation here
Rotten Tomatoes whenever there's like
thirsty material that comes through the
like rotten tomatoes it's like it's part
of our job to be like oh hey this is
what's coming down the pipe we should
know about it and if it's thirsty it is
always on my radar like you can't
surprise me when thirsty materials
coming down the pipe I am the pipe like
I know where it's coming from like I
know exactly who like the Thirsty
purveyors are what's a thirsty can you
give me an example of something thirsty
coming around in 65 days okay uh Lady
Chatterley's Lover oh anything that
Adrian Lynn does okay uh Jonathan
Major's bodybuilding no because it has
to be like a premise within the movie
Gone Girl oh okay gone girl's a good one
you know what I mean like fatal
attractions so just basically like again
this is not porn but it's just like like
sex movies or anything that is like
gearing towards that you want to know
something else that's in that you'd be
surprised hit me the bear
boom oh wow apparently sexual making
food yeah I mean because let me just
tell you there's a lot of ways you can
say yes chef
uh there's a lot there's a lot of noises
you make after eating at a delicious
Italian beef sandwich that might sound
like you're doing another activity
exactly so again so that's uh I do like
that I always find a way on my top 10
list to have something on there that
that speaks to those people those are
lists that's our list yeah and this is
the blitz to go great about this week
you guys get our full list as a part
from two episodes and we will start the
new year fresh with some new and
exciting stuff Mark do you know what we
actually have you've inspired me by the
way
um just we have we have a great slate of
movies we're going to be covering here
on this show week after week but also
just hearing your list I'm like I gotta
get back out I gotta see more movies
yeah you didn't get as many I had a good
movie you had a great I think you like
you know what it was you had good
Innings there weren't a lot of innings
but you had good Innings and that may be
better because there was a lot of crap
that I did not tell you about
that I saw this year a lot it's like
when we go back right the 70s were the
best time for music yeah because we
remember the good stuff yeah week after
week you had a lot of crap coming out in
the 70s like you know that like just
like scraped 10 off the top that's bad
that that 10 felt gooier this year Well
normal Years anyway you made it through
we definitely made it through I want to
remind everyone please let us know what
your top tens are you can let us know at
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong at put RT is
wrong at Rotten Tomatoes also don't
forget to subscribe rate and review tell
your friends we love it we have new
folks listen also for anyone that had us
on their Spotify wrapped Apple music
people I will go ahead and tell you
sorry you're messing the rotation up but
Spotify rap people there was several of
you that tagged us in your Spotify
wrapped we're very excited thank you
really appreciate it next week Mark what
do we have do you know uh no it's it's a
total mystery it's a total mystery to
you I will tell you it is because Megan
is coming out on one six and that is one
scary doll movie yeah and so we're gonna
have a different scary doll movie that
we're gonna talk about which is pride of
Chucky okay people like this movie yeah
it's got a cult following also I might
add for this one
um Chucky walk so Megan can run thanks
guys we'll see y'all next week
hi Rotten Tomatoes is wrong bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]